And the answer is 10 and this is a non-trivial answer.
So you could go and place the first heads anywhere in these five elements--say here--
and there's five different ways to place heads.
You can now place the second heads among the remaining four--for example, you could place it
over here and it gives you a factor of four different ways of placing the second heads.
But when you do this, you over count--you over count exactly by a factor of 2 in the business.
You place the first heads over here, the second over here, but if it was chosen to place
the first head on the right side and the second head over here on the left side,
and the outcome would've been exactly the same, so you counted the one twice
which means we have to divide it by 2--5 times 4/2 is 10